you are suited and booted you know this
is like you know this is the easy
pull-up game you see what i'm saying i
just did like something this light drift
i pull the jordans out you know with the
suited with the sweated suit the sweat
suit suit okay talk to him nice yeah
please do not do not pull up
so being on set working with tracy
morgan you guys are hilarious but what
is he like as your tv brother
i mean you know he's perfect i mean
because we we did last og together and
it was fun uh so he and i have a natural
kind of kendrick brothers spirit with
each other and so to have him on the
show
you know tracy got a gang of stories
always fun i know how to egg them on and
so that's what people would people would
be waiting for when they come on the set
then they wait for me to come around and
go man
i don't think you really like so-and-so
let me tell you about something you know
and he just go into a full-on tracy
morgan story yeah so it's funny but but
he was uh he was great you know great
attitude great spirit of pro and funny
looking look for it wanted to make his
character funny and so that's where we
really had a good time just developing
out uh you know especially to add you
know you didn't see a lot of calvin's
family on the show so
in these first four three seasons so in
season four
you'll get introduced to my my brother
and my mother so this is gonna be good
oh and your mother huh yeah wait who's
your mother
are we saying that where should i say it
somebody said she's pulling up
she uh on her own you know she is uh
lady marmalade maybe i'm just saying
without saying you know
oh
okay let me break that news
so i have to ask you're such a pro but
like do you
break character often like what makes
you just laugh and you forget your lines
max mac max is he
he's the culprit on our show of the king
of making you break characters so
because he's such a like a wild card and
his sense of humor is so dry and and
quick
and unexpected so he's the one that we
always like man somebody get max man
like not i'm trying to be serious i'm
supposed to be crying in this thing yeah
you know this me being sincere and here
he is over there
doing some max's smacks
so we love to see that you were at
russell peters wedding oh i appreciate
it like
like who like who the hell you think you
are officiating the wedding you know
russell said
russell said look man i've been married
before his friend his wife said i've
been married before we don't need that
one we don't want that one we want the
one that feels like us well a comedian
doing it doing so i got ordained online
and you know the fact that i'm original
king of comedy i believe that's an
ordination
that you know
so that's how i married them as original
king of comedy and the person who went
to the online california institute of
hey y'all ready to do this
dot com marriage license
we did it okay but it's official though
like
i had to sign documents and everything
thumb print
you know what i'm saying like you know
so
don't let them try to back out of it you
know if ever you see them be like
russell what's up he'd be like that was
real it was a whole new tick tock
and lastly congratulations on season
five y'all going long this could be like
a grey's anatomy like are you ready for
that ready for that that's the kind of
run i mean it's such a fun show with
dynamic cast we talk to
we talk to each other all the time about
you know like
really loving this show and is this
something that you would just want to
run with and everybody was like look you
know we've been
they've been on shows that got canceled
and you've been on shows where you go to
work every day and you love what it is
that you do and you have a good time
with the people that you do it with and
when you find those situations you just
want to run them you know
just go for a run man you know
well it was great talking to you you are
suited and booted we are happy we love
to see it yes yes indeed
appreciate it all right canada